Korey está organizando un concierto de música.
Planea invertir 2 mil pesos para alquilar el lugar
y pagarle a los músicos,
y luego vender los boletos a 20 pesos cada uno.
La gráfica de abajo muestra la ganancia "y"
que obtendría del concierto como una
función de los boletos vendidos "x".
esta gráfica de aquí
luego nos dicen,
si Korey decidiera vender los boletos
a 40 pesos cada uno.
¿Cuál sería la nueva gráfica de la ganancia?
y nos piden arrastrar los dos puntos
para mover la recta a la posición correcta.
Ok, pensemos en esto.
Si Korey vendiera ningún boleto,
si no vendiera boletos en absoluto,
entonces,
aún así tiene que pagarle a los músicos
y tiene que alquilar el lugar.
Así que perdería 2 mil pesos,
estarían menos 2 mil,
es lo mismo que sucede en esta gráfica de acá.
Ahora, si vendiera diez boletos...
vende diez boletos a 40 pesos cada uno,
eso significa
que gana de los boletos 400 pesos ,
pero tuvo que pagar 2000 de cualquier modo,
así que en realidad,
su ganancia sería de menos 2mil más 400,
que sería menos -1600.
Sigue sin ganar dinero.
Si vendiera 20 boletos,
20 por 40 son 800,
así que tendría que ganar -2000,
que son los que tienen que pagar,
más 800
que ahora sería 1200...
si vendiera 30, entonces ganaría
1200 pesos
pero aún así tiene que pagar 2000,
así que la gráfica quedaría aquí.
Pueden ustedes notar
que esta línea en realidad es la gráfica,
si vendiera 50 boletos a 40 pesos,
obtendría 2 mil pesos de los boletos
pero tuvo que gastar 2 mil
para pagar las cosas,
así que ahí,
saldría equilibrado
y no ganaría ni perdería dinero.
Si por el contrario vendiera 60 boletos,
60 por 40 son 2400,
así que gana 2400 de los boletos,
menos los 2 mil pesos
que tuvo que pagar por el alquiler
y para pagarle a los músicos,
obtendría 400 pesos de ganancia,
así que esta es la gráfica correcta.
Veamos.
Muy bien.